okay
playing some dude
while it's happening I've never played
Magnus on chess.com three Recaps from
Norway uh let me mute alerts and yeah
I just thought I'm feeling a huge rush
of the adrenaline right now
Madness giving me time odds
okay I'm minimizing chat completely so
I'm not looking at chat
deep rap
Stafford Abbott no let's play um let's
face the screen
late night C6
I play this line as white
um
I think A6
uh what's the line here
I mean just trying to focus
this is already a new territory for me
I think Bishop C5
and D5 could be a move
actually Knight um Knight C6 is logical
because I don't want to allow um the
eventual D4
I have Queen F6
and queen F6 also has some logic to it
then takes
of B5
B5 Bishop B3
D3
hmm
maybe I just take
I'm not sure here or D5 D5 immediately
then take try this
all those tie mods on Magnus gave me
have disappeared
takes
okay let's just Castle
take take
I don't think this should be so bad for
me
I'm down the pond but this Pawn is ugly
this move
and like Rook seed eventually
I have Bishop dxd4 here
then G3
that's not comfortable
you play Rook D first Rook C7 out of
this move
uh the G3 first
okay let me try and hold my ground at
least
nah I'm down about a minute I'm so
flustered wow he's stacking The Exchange
I mean I probably should take it
taken D4
a fancy move
but why no longer has a bishop pair
I have to do this
really
D3
not sure about this though
and something
that was not good
don't I was so nervous
I'm under the Rook I was already losing
um
after after losing G6
ah good game though
I hope people enjoy that game
wow Rook C5
I'm not sure if like he was toying with
me or that's just like a a strong idea
it makes some sense though
yeah The Rook
The Rook
it's hard to say The Rook was so much
enthusiasm when I was a victim of The
Rook
I tried to hold a slightly worse end
gaming as Magnus
it didn't quite work out
but I mean the position seemed okay
I guess the problem is I'm losing a pawn
and
yeah white has two pawns for the
exchange
and this chain is really strong
I mean White's probably like if I had to
guess plus one here
see
oh it's yeah engine briefly said equal
but light's already better what about
after Rook C5
Rook C5
engine likes black
but it requires like very accurate play
so dc5
rookie eight
uh rookie eight
yeah I mean I was kind of rushed to
close off the darks for a bishop
but maybe something like
could eventually rookie at F6
GG